what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I give my
thoughts over tea now that I used to be
addicted to coffee when I started this
it's funny I've done morning coffee
thoughts for over a year now
um just so you guys know I am going to
do a video addressing literally
everything I'm gonna go through
everything that has happened the last
last couple weeks
but unfortunately for certain reasons I
can't talk about certain things right
now
but I will I will when I can
so
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
what a misconceptions I feel like about
me it's funny because as a content
creator you're kind of in a position
where
you want to defend yourself
but at the same time you don't really
want to give like people attention that
just make money on you and don't like
you anyway so they're trying to spread
lies basically
however
I am going to address everything I am
well that's not what I'm talking about
today today I'm talking about
a common criticism that I get
um I watched this YouTuber
and I actually like her as a YouTuber I
really do and she made a video basically
saying that I'm basically the the
version of a feminist like how
I became
um basically it's wrong for me not to
push marriage when I grew up in a
situation that marriage benefited me so
well
so now that's that's a fair question why
don't you push marriage when you
personally saw the benefits of marriage
do you believe that women should get
married before they have kids
now there's two caveats to this answer
partially yes
I I partially do because
I do believe that's the best outcome for
the child however
I had
a heart I have a hard time
pushing marriage with how risky it is
for men and and that's the thing like a
lot of times as women we look at things
with our world view
right we're the kid so for us it's
better if the people are married me I
see things the way that a lot of men see
things because of the documentary I'm
doing on the court system
so I've talked about this before
um but
I've interviewed man after man after man
that is not and I'm doing another one
today
um that is not able to see his children
because of the way that the court system
is set up and it's set up this way in
many Western countries where women can
claim they were abused in the family
court system
now the entire
Community thinks he's an abuser then
they're legally able to take the kids
away and they're legally able to
financially destroy him oftentimes
leaving these men homeless or
financially ruined
how could I in good faith say go get
married
so
and and that's where the tough part is
for me because I I see firsthand what
could happen and a lot of these men and
the sad part actually is is that
marriage
take or leave but the kid is where they
financially ruin you because when a man
has a kid with a woman that kid isn't
his so I asked um this guy and he's a
lot smarter than me he's like a PhD in
history
um his name is David Baker
um he wrote the shortest history of the
world and sex two billion years of
procreation and Recreation and I
messaged with him sometimes
and I asked him how common because you
know the
uh fees is of the world the blue pill
guys their answer is like just pick the
right woman and how common is it really
that men get financially ruined in
divorced I think it's more common than
we think because I think a lot of men
don't talk about it because they're
embarrassed
um I mean are you really gonna tell the
people you work with and surround
yourself with that the woman you loved
for years
is financially ruining you in court
and also
um sorry guys I'm a little sick also is
um
what do you call it
accusing you of abuse is that something
you're really gonna share
so I asked him how common is this
because I'm just not a big numbers
person you know I I'm not great
and this is with the Clippers this is
what the reaction channels do they'll
clip it and be like see don't trust
anything she says she's not great with
numbers I hate
anyways
so I while I edited was editing the
American version of the shortest history
of sex I did some number crunching for
you it'll take me a second first I
dribbled down into the numbers behind a
study that hit the newspapers a few days
ago called Fortune families the effects
of wealth on marriage and fertility
by David sir Rainey
they looked at lottery winners in Sweden
where under Swedish law your spouse
cannot touch your lottery winnings
during a divorce when single men win in
the lottery their chances of getting
married increased by 30 percent their
fertility rate increases 13.5 percent
so rich men get more female attention
yawn so yeah okay
meanwhile when married men win the
lottery their chances of getting
divorced are reduced by 40 so the wives
stay with their husbands more because
they have more money makes sense
meanwhile when a woman wins the lottery
their probability of divorce increases
104 or basically doubles so essentially
the wife leaves because she doesn't need
her husband anymore and she thinks she
can do better meanwhile the probability
of divorce does not increase four women
who have been married for 10 years or
more probably because they're too old
and realize that we'll struggle finding
a new man who isn't a himbo gold digger
the tagline for this study was Lottery
wins increased a man's chance of
building a family and increase a woman's
chance at exiting one the results of the
study Accord with divorce statistics if
a woman stays at home as a stay-at-home
mother the divorce rate halves if the
man is a stay at home father less than
four percent of the population the
divorce rate doubles a separate 2018
study found that men doing more of
domestic cleaning duties do not increase
fertility rates or reduce divorce rates
probably because their wives don't want
to F their husbands after seeing them
prance around the house all day with a
feather duster
sorry guys there's there's a point and
so make sure stay because the the ending
of this is crazy furthermore a financial
issues are a factor in 55 of all
divorces women mostly women pissed off
their husbands aren't earning enough
money or the husbands lost their job so
no wonder women wives leave when they
win the lottery this also explains the
spike in divorce rate after 1970 as
women entered the work workplace in
masses in developing country as an equal
pay legislation legislation was passed
and it explains why in the post-1970
world 80 to 90 percent of divorces are
triggered by women they work the more
educated the better they have a job the
less they need their husbands Bottom
Line If a woman doesn't need the money
she has a very little reason to stay in
a marriage long term so women entering
the workforce in the last 50 years is a
primary reason Far and Beyond others as
to why marriages have gotten into the
sad state they're in and the fact that
women are ignoring biology and chasing
their careers in their 20s and family in
their 30s also explains why the
fertility rank tanked in developing
countries around 1973 to 1976
it would also explain why many single
women are all chasing top 5 10 and 15
percent of men why wealth and physical
attractiveness are such can are larger
considerations because with their
ability to earn their own money women
have no need whatsoever for Joe the
plumber unless he wins the lottery or is
extremely affable plumber to begin with
now I also ran the numbers for malicious
divorced rate
if we talk about total divorce cases if
we if we take total divorces and
eliminate 15 percent of abuses rather
than 20 allowing for a 25 [__] rate
which is a rough estimate for women
lying in their divorce petitions if we
include the 10 who collect alimony and
the eighty percent who are awarded child
support and factor in 15 of men who are
only allowed monthly visits 27 percent
of men who are awarded no visitation
rights and 23 percent of men who
surrender those rights
and we allow for a good portion of those
to be good faith decisions rather than
the women spitefully allowing fathers
access to their children
okay so we're factoring it we arrive at
a 30 to 35 percent malicious divorce
rate where women take their men to the
cleaners and limit and deny their access
to their children so one-third of all
divorces are the result of wives being
shitty to their husband rather than it
being irreconcilable differences with
Equitable settlements or mine or the
minority of cases of the husbands
divorcing their wives or the divorce
being otherwise amicable in a slightly
different weighing of variables I got 39
but one-third is a rough the best
estimate I can come up with at the
moment so a 45 divorce rate that amounts
to approximately 15 percent of marriages
resulting in wives effing over their
husbands just because they can't to put
this another way when a man gets married
he's got a slightly less than a 50 50
shot of it failing and he's got a one in
six chance of his wife maliciously and
utterly destroying his life how on Earth
can I advocate for marriage when when
the men's men signed that contract they
have a one in six chance of their wife
destroying their life
in developed countries around 1973 to
76.
um
it hit Japan first and radiated to other
developed Nations afterwards this is why
the impact of the birth control pill is
overstated Japan's fertility rates
tanked in the 70s and the pill was
illegal there until 1999.
it is simply more to do with a cultural
shift that encouraged young women in
their 20s to enter the workforce but
good for the economy but bad for biology
also
it this is the malicious divorce rate
where the wife either deliberately ruins
your life or does so to benefit herself
and doesn't give an f about what it does
to you there's plenty more than 15
percent of marriages that end in the
dude getting screwed in court these are
just the one where the wife seems to be
pathologically trying to inflict harm
divorce rate
held up 45 for several years because
marriage is half what it was 50 years
ago in the 70s
together
so I'm serious guys like from my point
of view when I know this and I interview
and I speak to the men that have been
wrecked by this institution
how can I advocate for this at least
until I understand the best ways how men
can protect themselves if they want to
have children and a family
how can I advocate for this when the
laws are the way they are
and then people will criticize me and
say I'm grifting because I in a way I
don't think that women should vote but
when women get the vote they make laws
that financially
ruin men to the point a lot of men
commit suicide in these situations
or y'all
Oreo you'll see the men freak out and
sometimes those guys that are that end
up like freaking out and killing the
girl
it's because the girl's been financially
ruining them for years
so how in good faith can I add and this
is genuine question Maybe I'm Wrong how
can I in good faith advocate for that so
it's not that I don't want people to get
married I think marriage is a beautiful
institution however
what is the point of getting married
if I have to argue with a beta no
offense it's no offense Destiny about
why you shouldn't get married over why
you shouldn't get divorced over chores
like at that point the the sanctity and
the institution of marriage is broken
anyway because what's the point like
marriage is supposed to be for Better or
For Worse for sickness and health for
richer for poor I I really don't even
believe that divorce should be legal
um
and that's because
the whole point of marriage is you're in
something and you can't get out no
matter what you have to figure out a way
to work it out you have to make it work
but how
so it's like people get married today
and it's not even real marriage
and it's it's sad because a lot of the
women that criticize me for this really
don't understand the laws they haven't
interviewed these men they haven't
spoken to these men they haven't you
know seen men cry because their kids a
mile away and they can't see them
and I'm not saying this to complain
about the problem but
all these people that say we're just
complaining the red pill is just
complaining while
um or I guess this is more of a mgtow
talking point I don't really care
um
and that you know I'm just grifting it's
like have you spoken to these men
have you have you talked to them have
you seen what this can do and a lot of
these men marry quote unquote good woman
and
a a spiteful woman
it changes her when people get power it
can change them and so to say just pick
the right woman it's it's a little
disingenuous
um
and I'm not saying you [__] like you
should try to pick the right woman but
again how do I advocate for that when
you've if you get divorced one out of
six chance
I think I forgot what he said but but
you see what I'm saying and that's
that's just malicious that doesn't even
mean you won't lose more so
and the real issue is having the kid as
what I've come to realize that you can
get married or not get married but the
real problems come when you have the kid
so I don't know guys let me know in the
comments am I crazy
um am I just promoting a world that just
focuses on the negative
um I don't know maybe I am but let me
know in the comments subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
pray for me because I am sick I'm sick
as hell like the video on your way out
and I'll talk to you next time